speaking of proportionality and sort of
moving on a little bit nigel we've
obviously gone through a very strange
period in the history of this country
and the world over the last couple of
years and we've seen you know i don't
think you're a big government guy
i'm not a big government guy and yet we
have seen i mean on the continent you
talk about germany and austria et cetera
locking unvaccinated people in their
homes fining etc but even in this
country i mean i love this country i've
made my home here and one of the reasons
i love it is
that you're free to do what you think is
the right thing whatever whatever the
situation is and you're free to have
your opinion until recently and so on
and so forth and over the last two years
we have seen the state attempting to
interfere in in things that i just don't
think it has a role in you know uh what
have you made of the last two years the
sort of authority vaccine passports the
idea of vaccine mandates all of that
horrified
by it all and
in the first 18 months of this
astonished
at the lack of pushback
you know you go do a poll and you know
64 percent agree we're locked down and
20 want to go further right ah what's
going on um
do you know what in the end
actually
the
good common sense
allied to a free press
have won the day
well let's remember we're sitting here
in the second week of february
mid-december
we had valence witty the brothers grim
we have we have we
i'm gonna
[Music]
[Laughter]
we had boris johnson do a sunday night
address to the nation
in which he used the word emergency four
times about omicron
all the while
we have the south africans
where this variant
had developed
telling the rest of the world unlike the
chinese but telling the rest of the
world what was coming our way and
explaining that it was much milder
than anything that had gone before and
in the end would help to build natural
immunity and might actually oddly
on balance be a good thing
so mid-december emergency lockdowns
catastrophe the end is nigh
second week of february
and restrictions about to end completely
how did that happen well it happened
because we have commentators
uh press you know free press
commentators arguing enough's enough
uh it happened because there was a back
bench rebellion
i mean the same mob
the same mob that fought theresa may
over brussels and all these things um
and the good
common sense of the british people has
come into play and that's put boris into
line
um interesting isn't it that the second
country
to follow this route is denmark
also a country that hasn't joined the
euro it's deeply euroskeptic and will no
doubt leave the euro all roads lead to
berlin
well but you can't deny it you know
so so actually
this is a good sign
the fact that we've gone in the space of
a few weeks
from looking like more lockdowns to
where we are is a very very good sign
that actually good common sense in the
end does prevail in this country
as for you know
what is happening in australia
and countries like that i just new
zealand i just can't get a handle on it
but it's not just those two it's austria
it's germany it's italy it's france
spain spain it's it's i i it's a
developed world thank god we've left the
european union
oh no i mean you know the vaccine roll
out all these things actually despicable
their behavior was despicable
stunning you know stunning um i mean the
way they behaved and you know the
guardian telling us that if we left the
european medicines agency it would prove
that brexit was a death cult but it's
all wrong
yeah look i'm very worried about this
growth of of huge government but i see
in canada
um as we speak it's day 13 of a protest
i generally
i'm pretty appalled by mob rule
but i don't see it as mob rule
everything indicates to me that the
truckers and their supporters are
behaving peacefully
behaving well that the attempts by
trudeau and others to smear them as
being far-right extremists simply aren't
working and this is a really big stand
um
and rather like we we've won the battle
on the nhs
vaccine mandate i've been banging on
about this on my show night after night
for weeks what's happening in canada
i think the pendulum is beginning
to turn back and i think it will start
to turn back
in other countries
um but we've seen the tendency haven't
we of governments to use any excuse any
crisis uh to build their power um and so
you know that's the next big battle
isn't it this is a battle genuinely for
liberty for freedom for individual
choice
and i am going to stick to my theme of
the last 30 years which is
globalist structures
whether it is
the european union whether it is
the united nations whether it is the
world health organization will always
seek to expand they seek to expand well
look at nato in the ukraine they seek to
expand geography we can have a big
argument
they seem to expand um but they seek to
expand their own powers and actually the
antidote to this
are democratically run nation states
with directly accountable politicians i
i honestly believe this all fits in to
the whole theme of my political life
nigel do not feel that with all the
lockdowns
the draconian measures that we've seen
what we've actually done is open a
pandora's box so next time there is a
particularly bad flu season for example
you know well we're going to have a few
restrictions otherwise the nhs is going
to be overwhelmed if there's a new
variant next year etc etc yeah climate
log downs
why not
i mean sadiq khan seems to be very keen
to drive every car off the roads of
london um what if the you know
part particle per million parts of
nitrous oxide reaches a certain level in
east london and they decide you know no
more cars for a week or yeah no i do
worry
i do worry that that president's been
set but i
i do worry about that but i still think
that this
victory
of common sense that we've achieved over
the last couple of months in the uk i
think that'll stand us in quite good
stead
i hope it'll stand us in quite good
stead but as for
austria germany new zealand
maybe it's gone it's funny isn't it
we seem to have a younger generation not
all of them but a younger generation
many of whom seem to think that values
matter more than freedom and liberty
and safety
and safety and the rule of law
um
i mean how a jury
how a jury in the
trial of the colston four
could decide that what happened wasn't
criminal damage
kind of shows you what i'm saying
yeah that that and when you when you
start to believe in these values
and these values become a substitute for
religion
you know whether it's
the fight against global warming the
fight against
racism historic wrongs it's a list as
long as your arm and you start to
believe
that your view
has a
a moral superiority
over people with another view
that's when you start to throw
things like liberty freedom justice rule
of law out of the window so these are
very big challenges going ahead and i
i think longer term
one of the big issues that we're going
to have to address
if we really do care
about the size of a state about
individual freedom
is the way young people are being
educated
and i think that is the real
cancer in society i mean i think that
it starts at primary school
this isn't just university this isn't
just a few sort of wacky lefty
professors this is actually right
through
the education system and we seem to have
stopped
teaching critical thinking
stop teaching stop teaching people that
you know here's a potential problem here
are two approaches to it they're both
valid
and you make your mind up which of these
you think is the right way to deal with
society
um and that's kind of been replaced by
well this one's
you know
good and moral and this one's evil so
that does pose
you know a bigger a big problem in the
years to come but i'm still
i'm still confident
i'm still bullish i still
i still think common sense is there i
still think there is a there is a when
push comes to shove a silent majority
who are for good things and sensible
things i still think we have
particularly brexit
an important leadership role
uh that we can be an example to others
in the world so yeah i can't help it i
still come out as the eternal optimist
[Music]